Speaker 1: Let's go to the discord lines. Phone
lines. Call them what you want. Let's hear from
the people in the audience. At the end of the
day, the most important people to the show
David Pakman dot com slash discord is where
you can find the discord. And let's start
today with Diego from Jacksonville, Florida.
Diego, welcome. What's on your mind today?
Diego. Welcome. What is on your mind today?
And Diego is gone. Let's go next
to Paul from Saint Louis. Paul from
Saint Louis. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Can you hear.
Speaker 1: Me? I can hear you fine, my friend.
Speaker 3: Beautiful. So I had a quick comment
about your interview with Mike Lindell, and I
know we've beaten this to death already. Sure.
But I showed that interview to a friend of
mine, and he insisted that Mike Lindell,
instead of being just unable to come up with
his own thoughts and trying to like get these
numbers from what was it, Minnesota.
Speaker 1: Wisconsin, I think in the
interview I did with him, yeah.
Speaker 3: Yeah. So instead of
that, he's just being dishonest. And I said,
I don't know. I feel like he really is a true
believer and believes what he's saying. But
what I would like to see if you actually do
interview him again in the future. Yeah. Is
communicate with him ahead of time. Listen,
I might ask you about this. I would like to I'd
like for you to have those numbers in front of you
so that we can actually discuss and, like, really
drill down into what these numbers are telling us.
Speaker 1: In a practical sense, it's basically
impossible that the community. So that would
make sense, like in a logical planet where the
communication with him and his team makes sense.
But based on the way that these interviews
get booked and what the communications like,
that is an impossibility. It's not an
unreasonable suggestion. You're making
a completely reasonable suggestion. It'll
just never happen the way they it's. It's
a miracle. He even ends up in front of the camera
at the time. Roughly at the time we've agreed on.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I, I think that is very fair.
I do think that in that interview he was the
most lucid I think I've ever seen him.
Speaker 1: Well, you know, you're right
in a sense, but there's a question of,
okay, he sounds articulate and lucid,
but at the same time, if he's literally
just making the things up as he goes along,
it's not particularly it's not real lucid
lucidity. And if he's delusionally believing
these things, that's also not really lucid. I
think what you mean is he just sounded coherent.
Speaker 3: Yes, that's exactly what I mean.
Speaker 1: Right, right. Right. No, I agree
with you. He did sound more coherent, although
the things coming out of his mouth made no sense.
Speaker 3: Okay. One more quick question.
Is there a time slot that you are booking
for him or is it his people telling you,
okay, this is how much time that he has?
Speaker 1: So I was I our producer, Pat
handled the logistics. If I recall correctly,
the interview was roughly at the normal
time we proposed. So it seems to me that
we kind of proposed the time and he agreed to it.
Speaker 3: Okay. Yeah, because I was wondering if
there's a way to like, you know, instead of like
really just let him find those numbers and just
sit there until he comes up with them, you know?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, you're everything you're
saying makes sense. It's just like when you're
actually producing a show, if things don't
necessarily work out where that that's plausible.
Speaker 3: Sure. Okay, well, that's all. I did it.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend. Thank you
very much. Yeah, I know a lot of people with
a lot of questions about the logistics
of the pillow interview and others.